i really do believe
that vcon1
may 19th to the 22nd in minnesota will
be like one of those events
i am having the best time in my life man
of course i know who you are peg i pay
attention to the community it is no
question in my opinion the most
significant nft web 3 conference thrown
i'm really glad we're together
because i am like taking back the
information to my children this guy
changes a lot of people's lives and uh
i'm just i couldn't be more excited
about it be friends
welcome to v con
[Applause]
i'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real
[Music]
franchise best on the team all right
gary thanks for joining me today so you
are on the ground in minneapolis for
v-con what is it like to see this in
person it's crazy you know the
excitement's there i mean the lines are
already huge this morning we had the
kickoff party last night that went
tremendously well
[Music]
and you know to be frank i'm just kind
of focused on over delivering uh to the
uh thousands of people that have uh
attended this
you need them to event [ __ ] all that
talk and i'll leave it to you cause i
gotta go gotta meet in that too tell me
why all of the [ __ ] that you saying
don't ever match up with that [ __ ] that
you do
it feels like i'm definitely like
different energy you know
like definitely like
super focused
really genuinely
just trying to
make sure everybody has a good time you
know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good so that's all i care about
i'm not worried about um
wow
all right honestly that's the only clip
i ever want to share on social media
just so you know what just happened
i
by the way the left catch was legit
[Applause]
i will run that clip for the next 50
years
[Music]
[Applause]
finally
please welcome
ceo and creator of be friends gary
vaynerchuk
[Music]
my name is gary vaynerchuk
series two
[Music]
okay i just want to save someone's
[ __ ] gratitude okay you know like i'm
just so [ __ ] happy to be the only
real authentic
garyvee
[Music]
right check one two hold on one second
[ __ ]
bro what the hell are you
i'm garyvee series three what the [ __ ]
are you dead
bro i'm guaranteeing something chewing
it
authenticity right yeah perspective yeah
really i have a [ __ ] question for you
my man can you talk about blueberries no
no no
[ __ ] nice so much
holy [ __ ] you bite your nails can i get
a hit of that yeah i should go [ __ ]
yo gary too that's just amazing okay
honestly i really believe okay
i think between the two of us we're
amazing it's almost like who needs the
original garyvee
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one more time for the fellas
the friends
welcome to v-con
i have a very scaled vision for this and
i'm very excited to operate it i will
navigate this the way i've navigated
everything in my life
with supreme effort
with a hell of a lot of hard work
with a lot of clever smarts
and with tremendous good intent
i make you that promise and i'm humbled
by your support
[Music]
the ability to find negativity on an
every hour basis is extremely easy the
thing that i am far more interested in
is the ability to find positivity is
there at all times as well if i had one
big massive macro goal for vcon if vcon
can be the extra juice the extra little
push to tip some of you over that are on
your journey to deciding to be
optimistic versus defaulting into being
pessimistic if this event and other
people's love towards you the love that
likely if you are that person you are
not given along the way if this
community can do that for each other if
this event can be the container of that
this would be a remarkable weekend and
so i asked the people at this conference
that if you were happy and optimistic to
over communicate that to every friend
you make to step up to your fellow v
friend that might not be there and try
to build that bridge i genuinely believe
that people are really missing the
simplicity of life
choosing to be optimistic and happy
is hard when you were built to be
negative and cynical recognizing its
truth
and putting in the work no different
than doing exercise or eating better or
reading and learning about web 3
recognizing that truth and putting
yourself on a path to try to go there is
not as difficult
and so
i hope that we can choose practical
optimism this weekend and i encourage it
very much
and i just want to say that i adore you
i love you i can't wait to see you and
have the greatest
greatest
greatest
greatest
greatest
v-con
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't even realize what she just did
on stage
you completely changed my brain
from
you should have came to a keynote
earlier
i love you i love you
so proud of you
is
thanks for having us on course of course
you changed a lot of [ __ ] for me man i
truly appreciate that i'm [ __ ] record
four cameras bro yeah all right this guy
changes a lot of people's lives shout
out to this [ __ ] for all the
people who are like hey don't hate him
because i'm like guys hey you love it
sing here this is the most love of all
time every time i do a video everyone's
like yo man i i love gary but yo this is
hilarious i'm like i love him too
[Music]
[Applause]
when you are a human that has a project
and you can now own or issue things that
are ownable because of the blockchain it
changes everything i'm in the royalty
business tomorrow i can reward everybody
that has the
you know optimistic otter because
affirmation of the ledger provides it
it's a functionally operational
infrastructure of technology that allows
me to create
and benefits both sides of the equation
like i only win if they win
i've been working here for six years
since this place opened i've been
preaching about you bro i feel like i'm
manifested
thank you who knows my career might be
over here soon at least i got to see you
first my dude real pleasure to meet you
thanks for saying what's up
[Music]
love it thank you so much thank you for
everything you're doing thank you so
much thank you thank you
that's the logo
the very very very very lucky black cat
is the logo of the whole project
that's my pikachu that's my mickey mouse
with me if you ride with me you can
slide with me if you feel like 550 on
the fast sticky come get high with me
that's a deal right ride with
[Music]
glad you're here i'm glad to be here man
it's going well so far dude i'm a
[ __ ] introvert man and when i bought
my vf1 last year i'm like i'm going to
come here i'm going to probably by
myself man i'm proud of you [ __ ]
nervous as hell no don't be what's your
name brad have you made some friends
yeah man junior are you wearing bill
[ __ ] every day
that's very disrespectful
let's take this photo
thanks brother thank you for everything
great
make sure you say hello to people lean
into the left precipitation i ain't
never met a limitation i hate applying
my elimination gotta go to google for
the information i'm a superstar so i
gotta shine
my mask my friend professional parkour
and world chase tag athlete no kidding
backflip every single day today is 185.
can i do one for you you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
such a pleasure so um earlier this year
it was a hard year for me um you know i
even have like i choose life you know
but um i listen to your stuff and you
know you help me through it so
pleasure man what's your name john john
i'm really glad we're together me too
man can i write something i'd love that
[Music]
my man what i'm writing here is the
biggest truth in the world
it's just deciding what to look at
[Music]
it's just like tilting your head and
turning around and looking at it
differently
and you have the strength to do that
every day
thank you man you're welcome
make sure you look at that when you need
it promise yeah yeah
you just have to look at something that
is good
there's always something that's good too
every day there always is
i promise yeah i have my mom good thing
i love that good brother
[Music]
harry wake us up
[Applause]
how are you i'm going to get some rest
i'm tired
you're a little tired
[Music]
the astronaut's crazy
[Music]
you having fun
kids always know
[Music]
i don't want to do it anymore but i did
my master's in bachelors like i went
through [ __ ] school got my pe the wit
the waste
it's not that you wasted your time in
school and don't do it the way says if
you keep doing it when you know it's
wrong even though you did your time in
school
you know that right everybody thinks oh
[ __ ] i got my masters i spent all this
time i spent all this money but every
day parents are immigrants so i felt
like i had you know
you know my content i talk about it
every [ __ ] day i know what you
thought you had to do yeah but you know
what you hate it i did it will only get
worse
stop get the [ __ ] out okay get the [ __ ]
out
[Music]
bye cliff
yeah why cliff's killing it
alex
why clef
kill it he's the best you know what i
did but i sent him a tweet to make sure
everyone was there
okay gary it's packed all of a sudden
out of nowhere we're like where the [ __ ]
did all these people come from i put on
twitter
[Music]
i'm [ __ ] down
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my money
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
when i say the word curiosity where does
that take you curiosity is the life
force in all of us the minute that you
stop being curious that's it your life
is over
[Music]
you